[Música]
el presidente colombiano Gustavo Petro
confirmó que fueron hallados con vida
los cuatro menores que desaparecieron el
pasado Primero de Mayo y de los que no
se tuvo noticia en 40 días los niños se
perdieron en la amazonía colombiana
luego de que la aeronave en la que
viajaban se estrellara
el expresidente de Estados Unidos Donald
Trump se enfrenta a 37 cargos en medio
de la investigación por los documentos
clasificados que fueron hallados en su
residencia de Florida dos de sus
abogados dimitieron y se espera que
otros expertos se unan a su defensa en
los próximos días
la presidenta de Perú Dina boluarte
presentó un polémico balance de sus seis
meses de gestión asegurando que logró
restablecer el orden constitucional en
el país esto cuando esta misma semana la
mandataria tuvo que declarar ante la
fiscalía por los presuntos abusos de la
fuerza pública en las protestas en las
que murieron unas 60 personas ampliamos
desde Lima
Bienvenidos a esta informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos comenzamos en
Colombia porque el presidente Gustavo
Petro confirmó que fueron hallados los
menores los cuatro menores de uno cuatro
nueve y Trece años que estaban
desaparecidos desde el pasado Primero de
Mayo el rastro de los niños se perdió
luego de que la avioneta cesna en la que
viajaban con su madre y otras dos
personas se accidentara en la selva
amazónica colombiana los menores
recibieron atención médica trasera
encontrados Bueno hoy hemos tenido un
día mágico
indudablemente llena de alegrías
acercarnos y tocar la paz
en el acuerdo que avanza con el eln y
ahora
regreso y la primera noticia es que
efectivamente las comunidades indígenas
que estuvieron en la búsqueda y las
fuerzas militares conjuntamente
encontraron a los niños 40 días después
estaban solos habían sido ellos mismos
lograron un ejemplo de sobrevivencia
total digamos que quedará en la historia
así que esos niños son hoy los niños de
la paz y los niños de Colombia seguimos
hablando de Colombia pero vamos a Cuba
donde el viernes Finalizó el tercer
ciclo de conversaciones entre el estado
colombiano y la guerrilla del ejército
de liberación nacional un encuentro que
dejó como principal resultado de un
acuerdo de cese el fuego a partir del 3
de agosto y que estará vigente según lo
previsto durante 180 días el pacto tiene
una particularidad Y es que habrá una
etapa de pedagogía previo a su
implementación además no contempla Según
uno de los comandantes de la guerrilla
la suspensión de secuestros y
extorsiones de ese grupo delincuencial
Rafael Pérez tiene los detalles
un paso firme en Cuba hacia un acuerdo
definitivo así se desarrolló el cierre
del Tercer ciclo de negociaciones de paz
entre el gobierno colombiano y grupo
guerrillero en activo más grande del
país el eln en el encuentro se firmaron
varios lineamientos para facilitar el
diálogo entre ellos un cese al fuego que
comenzará el 3 de agosto y se extenderá
por 180 días el más largo pactado hasta
ahora rebajar la intensidad del
conflicto para que en Colombia
haya un mejor clima para la
participación de la sociedad en este
proceso de paz ese consideramos que es
de los aportes importantes de los
acuerdos que hemos suscrito acá el alto
el fuego se desarrollará bajo la ejida
de varios mecanismos de monitoreo la ONU
el gobierno la Iglesia Católica y
contará con un proceso pedagógico previo
para discutir las prohibiciones que se
harán efectivas que este firma de estos
acuerdos
parciales hoy que los llevan a ustedes a
un cese al fuego a un punto que nunca
habían experimentado en los diálogos
a un cese al fuego que sigue con una
promesa
el 25 de mayo en mayo del 2025
cesa definitivamente la guerra de
décadas entre el eln y el estado de
Colombia
Naciones Unidas reaccionó el acuerdo de
cese el fuego la ONU lo calificó como un
paso importante que da Esperanza al
pueblo colombiano la cuarta Ronda de
diálogos tendrá lugar en Venezuela entre
el 14 de agosto y el 4 de septiembre
vamos a Estados Unidos donde el
expresidente y precandidato presidencial
por el partido republicano Donald Trump
fue imputado con 37 cargos por el
Departamento de Justicia el motivo es la
presunta violación a numerosas leyes
relativas a la seguridad nacional
después de que en agosto de 2022 el FBI
encontrara más de 100 documentos
clasificados en la residencia del
expresidente Mara lago Trump ha
reafirmado en varias ocasiones su
inocencia y ha descrito el proceso legal
como una cacería de brujas ligada al
partido demócrata el informe es de Max
Pérez Gallardo
Donald Trump imputado por el
Departamento de Justicia las autoridades
estadounidenses dieron a conocer el acta
de acusación contra el expresidente
dicho documento indica que el también
Magnate enfrenta 37 cargos relativos a
la violación de leyes sobre seguridad
nacional El fiscal encargado del caso
Jack Smith reveló el informe donde se
incluyen los cargos contra Trump y
agregó que nadie está por encima de la
ley
al Estado de derecho es un principio
básico del departamento de justicia y el
compromiso de nuestra nación con el
estado de derecho es un ejemplo para el
mundo en este país tenemos un conjunto
de leyes que aplican para todo el mundo
el ahora precandidato republicano para
los comicios presidenciales de 2024 ha
arremetido en numerosas ocasiones contra
el fiscal Smith llegando a calificarlo
como un psicópata a través de una
publicación en la plataforma
es propietario en el mismo mensaje el
expresidente tilda la actual presidente
estadounidense Joe biden como un
criminal biden ha sido blanco de
críticas en las redes sociales de Trump
que acusa al presidente demócrata de
utilizar al departamento de justicia en
su contra el mandatario estadounidense
ha expresado que no ha hablado sobre
Trump con la cabeza del departamento de
justicia
presidente biden ha hablado ya con el
fiscal general no he hablado con él en
lo absoluto no voy a hablar con él no
tengo ningún comentario sobre lo
ocurrido tras la revelación del acta
acusadora Trump está citado a comparecer
ante una corte en Miami el martes 13 de
junio seguimos en Nicaragua un tribunal
de Managua ordenó a la procuraduría
general expropiar los bienes de los 222
expresos políticos desterrados por el
gobierno Daniel Ortega el fallo
divulgado el viernes establece el
decomiso a favor del estado de Nicaragua
de todas las acciones y las sociedades
mercantiles que los condenados tengan
según los magistrados del tribunal la
decisión hace parte de la resolución que
en febrero ordenó el destierro inmediato
de más de 200 disidentes del régimen
autoritario de Daniel Ortega
la ong
alertó que el gobierno hondureño no
tiene voluntad política para establecer
una comisión internacional contra la
corrupción la directora de la
organización para las Américas Juanita
govertus aseguró que el país cuenta con
decretos legislativos que obstaculizan
una debida investigación y hacen que los
procesos contra diputados No avancen
adecuadamente
pide eliminar esas trabas y asegura que
en más de un año del actual
administración no sea materializado la
adecuada instalación de la comisión
contra la corrupción no establecer
mecanismos efectivos de lucha contra la
corrupción genera graves violaciones a
los derechos humanos en materia de salud
en materia de acceso a servicios
públicos básicos en materia de consulta
previa de comunidades indígenas en
materia claramente de lucha contra la
pobreza y de la desigualdad a veces
vemos la corrupción como un tema
abstracto desligado de los Derechos
Humanos cada acto corrupto genera como
resultado de ello violaciones a los
Derechos Humanos
en Perú la presidenta Dina boluarte hizo
un balance de sus seis meses frente al
gobierno y aseguró que en este tiempo ha
logrado entre otros puntos preservar el
orden democrático del país recordemos
que esta semana boluarte testificó ante
la fiscalía dentro de la investigación
por la muerte de cerca de 60 personas en
medio del estallido Social tras la
captura de Pedro Castillo Francisco
Zacarías corresponsal de France 24 en
Lima nos contó los demás aspectos clave
del balance de la jefa de estado
la presidenta Dina boluarte dijo que
sujeción ha avanzado en garantizar el
orden democrático recuperar la
estabilidad y también en enfocar la
atención a las necesidades más urgentes
la mandataria señaló que Perú se
encuentra en la vitrina de los
inversionistas extranjeros tras la
crisis política y social que sufrió esa
nación en los primeros meses de este año
la mandataria reveló que de enero a mayo
Perú registra más de tres mil
ochocientos millones de dólares en
inversión pública y tras criticar a sus
adversarios la jefa de estado dijo que
la violencia no produce nada y por eso
pidió a los líderes de otros partidos
ser portadores de la paz y no de la
violencia la presidenta boluarte también
fue enfática al desmarcarse de la
corrupción y dijo que en su gestión
ningún ministro viceministro ni el
Primer Ministro ni la presidenta venga
al Perú como una bolsa para enriquecerse
pinta el informativo gracias por su
sintonía
[Música]